-Jay Pharoah, welcome back.
It's always great to see you.
-Yeah, it's great to be here.
-Thank you for coming back.
-Thank you.
-Last time you were on the show,
you did a great impression
of Dwayne Johnson.
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-We had Dwayne on the show...
-Uh-huh.
-...and played the impression
for Dwayne to see his reaction.
And he loved it.
-Yeah, he was --
-He loved it.
-Yeah, he --
Dwayne has always been --
Y'all got to under--
When I was a little kid,
I used to want to be The Rock.
I was -- I told --
-I still want to be The Rock.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
'cause he's --
[As The Rock] I mean,
yeah, he's just so cool.
And, yeah, he's that guy
that just says things,
and he's like --
Yeah, you know,
he's just a great guy.
And, uh...
Yeah, it's just...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Normal voice] It was
so crazy because I went --
I went to
the "Black Adam" premiere,
and, you know,
I went there to support him.
Also, Aldis Hodge
and also Mo Amer.
And I saw Dwayne
walking past me,
and I said,
"Yo, man, what's up?"
-He was like --
[As The Rock] "Hey, come here.
Me and Jimmy
were just talking about you."
And he said,
"I'll send you the bill."
[Normal voice] I said,
"What is he talking about?"
I had one of those, you know --
You remember
"Diff'rent Strokes"?
Is that what it's called?
"Diff'rent Strokes" with...
-Arnold.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
And then, you know --
Whatchu talkin' about, Willis?
I was like, "Whatchu
talkin' about, Dwayne?"
'Cause I didn't know
what he meant.
But he --
he was talking about the show.
He said --
That was so nice of him.
And I didn't know
until my Twitter blew up,
and people were like,
"Dwayne just said your name!"
My grandmother was like,
"Dwayne just said your name."
-Yeah, that's a good thing.
You know, you do
so many great impressions.
And you were telling me
backstage that you got cast
in a Steven Soderbergh movie.
-Absolutely.
I got cast
in a Steven Soderbergh movie
called "Unsane."
If you haven't seen it,
check it out.
But I got cast in that movie
off of my Denzel Washington
impression
because back --
[ Light applause ]
Yeah, real talk.
I mean, I heard the clap.
You can clap. It's fine.
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
A little clap.
There was a little clap.
So, what happened was,
Matt Damon showed
Steven Soderbergh
my Denzel Washington impression.
And, you know, Soderbergh
looked at it, and he said,
[As Soderbergh] "Well,
that's good. Yeah, I like that."
So after -- he -- Years later --
It had to be -- It was 2017.
He hit me up about this movie,
and he said,
"I could tell that
you have dramatic chops
by looking at you doing
that Denzel impression.
Because to be able to capture
a character like that,
you have to be able
to act like somebody else."
And that -- So off of
my Denzel impression --
Off the Denzel impression,
I booked it.
[As Denzel] Yeah. I booked it
with Steven Soderbergh.
That's what I did, huh?
Okay. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so wild, bud.
-[Normal voice] Yeah, yeah.
-You have --
You have over 200 impressions.
-Absolutely.
-And last time you were
on the show, I challenged you
to do as many impressions
as you could in 60 seconds.
-Yeah.
And I was just wondering
if you'd be up
for doing it again
with different impressions.
-I don't know. This is...
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'll do it. I'll do it. Yeah.
I can do it.
-So, what we'll do is...
we'll put 60 seconds
on the clock,
and I will prompt you with
different names in no order.
I'm just gonna go off --
These are names
I got off the website
that say -- that I heard
that you can do.
-Okay.
-Okay. Are you ready for this?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-60 seconds with Jay Pharoah.
-Whew!
-Tracy Morgan.
-[As Morgan]
Hey, that's impossible.
Why would I do that one?
Everybody's getting pregnant.
-Uh, Nicolas Cage.
-[As Cage]
You know what, Jimmy?
You're so good
at impersonations.
And this one is just like that.
Aha! Alright. Next.
-Stewie from "Family Guy."
-[As Stewie] Oh, yes.
Jimmy, we're gonna have
a sexy party,
and everyone's
going to come here.
Yakety yak yak yak.
-Chris Tucker.
-[As Tucker] Hey, man, I don't
even know why you gonna ask me
that, man.
That's crazy, man. Insane, man!
-President --
President Joe Biden.
-[As Pres. Biden]
It's just -- Come on, man.
Just ridiculous, man.
Everybody needs
to get vaccinated.
Now, if you get vaccinated,
we'll have something
called herd immunity.
We'll give you a bag of weed.
Alright.
-Alright. Jason Statham.
-[As Statham]
You know, Jason Statham
is that person
that's just like --
You know, I'm gonna get there,
I'm gonna hit you in the face,
and I'm gonna tear it off
and I'm gonna eat it. Ergh!
-John Legend.
-[As Legend]
♪ We're ordinary people ♪
♪ We don't know
which way to go... ♪
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Yeah! Yeah!
[ Bell dinging ]
Come on! Come on! No!
Come on! Come on! Come on!
You laughed through it!
We had more!
-I just wanted --
I wanted one more!
-You have more!
-There was two more
I wanted to get to. Can I?
-Come on. Please.
-Do you mind? Bonus?
-Yeah. No. We have to.
Let's go. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do it.
-Chris Rock.
[As Chris Rock]
Oh, come on, man!
Okay? Okay?
I got smacked by
the softest person in the world.
Okay? Okay.
-Richard Pryor.
-[As Pryor] Man, that's insane
that you asked me to do Pryor
'cause I'm on
national television
and I can't say a damn thing.
[ Laughter ]
-John Mulaney.
-[As Mulaney]
Oh, well, that's crazy, Jimmy.
You'd ask me
to do John Mulaney.
I'm with Olivia Munn,
and I'm loving it!
It's amazing.
-Oh, my God.
-Come on.
That's Jay Pharoah right there.
Come on, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow. Wow.
Thank you for doing that.
-Yeah, man.
-But is that
what people could see
when they see you do stand-up?
-What? What? Just --
You mean just as far as,
like, impre-- Of course.
Impressions, yeah,
but now it's like --
It's -- It's morphing, dude.
And it was impression-heavy.
But I remember
the first time --
I remember killing on stage
in New York
at Carolines on Broadway.
And Charlie Murphy
took me there.
-Carolines is where I --
It was one of the clubs
I started at, too.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shout-out to Caroline.
-Caroline. Caroline Hirsch.
-Yeah. Caroline Hirsch.
And Louis.
-Louis...
-Louis Faranda.
-Louis Faranda. Yep.
Caroline Hirsch
and Louis Faranda.
-They were great.
-Man, I was 19 years old,
and Charlie Murphy took me
on the road with him.
-Charlie Murphy?
-Yeah. Charlie Murphy.
[As Murphy]
Y'all know Charlie Murphy, man.
Talk like this, man.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's like, "Yo, son.
I got to take you
on the road with me, man.
You hilarious, man. Yeah!"
[Normal voice] I'm like,
"Is he gonna kill me?
What is happening?"
-How'd you do?
-Dude, so,
I got a standing "O"
the third show Saturday night,
and I didn't expect it.
I did this Cam'Ron
and Dipset impression,
which bit -- it killed --
and everybody gets up.
[ Imitates crowd cheering ]
And then I trip on stage,
and I was like,
"No! I don't feel like
it counts anymore!"
-"I got a standing 'O,'
and then..."
-I got a standing "O,"
and then -- and then I'm clumsy.
The clutch just came out.
And I remember
going to the green room.
And Uncle Ray, Eddie Murphy
and Charlie Murphy's uncle,
was standing right there,
and he said,
"That was great, but, uh,
we got to work on your balance."
[ Laughter ]
Real talk.
-Just gotta work
on your balance.
-But it worked out.
-It did work out.
-It worked out
'cause here you are.
You're in a big movie.
-Absolutely.
-Let's talk about
"Spinning Gold."
-Yeah. "Spinning Gold," man.
-It's about
the Casablanca Records story?
-It's the story
of Casablanca Records
and Buddah Records.
And Neil Bogart, who was the
founder of Casablanca Records,
he, you know -- he came up --
Donna Summers. KISS.
Bill Withers.
The Isley Brothers.
-P-Funk.
-I remember Casablanca Records.
Donna Summer.
"Bad Girls" record. Yeah.
-Dude, like, so ma--
I didn't know --
-Village People.
Who else is up there?
Kurtis Blow.
Like, so much history in that.
And I'm playing Cecil Holmes,
the co-founder --
the co-founder
of Casablanca Records.
And he is --
he's the backbone, man.
Anything Neil Bogart needed,
he was his ride-or-die.
And I didn't have any footage
or anything to use this time.
So it was really just me
going off of what Tim Bogart,
his son,
who directed the film,
telling me about Cecil
and using personal --
you know, my personal
relationships to get into it.
-What years were these set in?
'70s?
-1970s and top of the '80s.
Yeah, man.
-Fun time.
-Fun time. Whew!
-Can't do what you --
Can't do none of that no more.
-No, no, no, no, no.
I know there's a --
I want to say there's --
there's some connection to --
we're gonna show this clip --
about "The Tonight Show"
and Casablanca Records.
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-I didn't know about this.
That Johnny Carson,
they made a --
They made a record?
-Yeah, they did a Johnny Carson.
They decided to record him,
Johnny Carson, live.
And the funniest thing
is that it did --
it did so bad that --
The joke is that more records
were returned
than Casablanca put out.
You know what I mean?
Which is insane.
But, you know, and that's --
that's where me and --
me and Neil Bogart --
Jeremy Jordan plays him.
That's where we get
into this argument,
like, in the movie.
Like, there's a part
in the movie
where we're just --
we're just butting heads
because I don't know
where this is going.
I'm like, "Dude,
I followed you all the way.
I'm your brother.
But we are losing --
I can't. I don't have --
Nobody has any money."
They didn't have any money.
They were $7 million in debt
when they did that.
-Even with Donna Summer?
-Even with --
Donna Summer came after.
She came right after that.
And that's when Donna Summer
saved Casablanca Records.
-Whew!
-Real talk.
Real talk. Real talk.
-I want to show a clip.
-Here's Jay Pharoah
in "Spinning Gold."
Take a look at this.
-Neil. Neil!
-What?!
[ Telephone rings ]
-What if we were wrong
about Carson?
-I mean, we're shipping gold.
More.
Over 750,000 copies already.
And with the money we're
spending on commercials
and print ads...
-It's Johnny [bleep] Carson!
-Nobody understands why the hell
we're even doing it.
-Then ship more! Spend more!
Do your job
and make them understand
this is gonna be the biggest
[bleep] album of the year!
Okay, folks?
-You've lost your mind.
Did you not hear
what they said on the phone?
And they were
on our [bleep] side.
-Nobody is on our [bleep] side!
-'Cause nobody understands
what the [bleep]
you're doing anymore!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who was that guy?
-Uh, I'm -- I don't know.
I don't know.
-Come on. Well done.
-I don't know.
-Yeah, I know.
That's Jay Pharoah right there!
-"Spinning Gold"
is in theaters this Friday.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Coco Jones.
Stick around, everybody!